your lawyer up I guess in a way I am
yeah yeah and I should have said to you
before Anderson because the facts matter
here I'm gonna be on another network
tomorrow that thinks I should be in jail
well that was quite something first of
all with the we asked questions we've
been following this investigating this
we can definitively say that the Fox
News Network does not think that James
Comey should be in jail as a statement
of fact we are asking questions that
lawmakers are asking on Capitol Hill
believe it or not after this book roll
out and this book tour now the questions
tonight we are looking for substance and
there are things on the table that have
not been asked and this is special
reports bite at the Apple we'll have him
live in studio and we'll see what comes
out we look forward to that and there
was also this moment where James Comey
took he took the moment to analyze the
way the president thinks listen to this
his only reference point is internal
what will bring me what I need what will
fill this hole in me get me the
affirmation I crave and that's deeply
concerning because the only way you make
hard decisions is by looking to the
external reference punch that was his
response and and answering a question
about the president's leadership style I
think there are many questions to ask
about James commis leadership style
about how he handled the Clinton email
investigation how he handled the Trump
investigation and his decisions along
the way specific substance that we
haven't heard as of yet and I hope to
get some of that tonight we should let
you go prepare for that because we will
all be watching Bret Baier be sure to
watch them tonight thanks for your time
this morning Bret and you're sitting
down with James Comey one-on-one that's
only on special report at 6:00 p.m.
Eastern Time right here on the Fox News
Channel I don't know about you but Rick
I will be oh absolutely I will be
sitting down and ready for that James
Comey saving the best for last Brett who
also has dragon energy we're going back
to the gun US
I love that he has so much to ask that
hasn't been asked yet of Comey
like that's really important there's a
lot out there and we know Brett will do
we can count